Welcome back guys.
Today we're going to work on
a problem that tests your
knowledge of joint PMFs.
And we're also going to get
some practice computing
conditional expectations and
conditional variances.
So in this problem, we
are given a set of
points in the xy plane.
And we're told that these points
are equally likely.
So there's eight of them.
And each point has a
probability of 1/8 of occurring.
And we're also given this
list of questions.
And we're going to work
through them together.
So in part a, we are asked to
find the values of x that
maximize the conditional
expectation of y given x.
So jumping right in, this
is the quantity
we're interested in.
And so this quantity
is a function of x.
You plug-in various
values of x.
And then this will spit
out a scalar value.
And that value will correspond
to the conditional expectation
of y conditioned on the value
of x that you put in.
So let's see, when x is equal
to 0, for instance, let's
figure out what this value is.
Well, when x is equal to 0
we're living in a world,
essentially, on this line.
So that means that
only these two
points could have occurred.
And in particular, y can only
take on the values of 1 and 3.
Now, since all these points in
the unconditional universe
were equally likely, in the
conditional universe they will
still be equally likely.
So this happens with
probability 1/2.
And this happens with
And therefore, the expectation
would just be 3/2 plus 1/2
which is 4/2, or 2.
But a much faster way of seeing
this-- and it's the
strategy that I'm going to use
for the rest of the problem--
is to remember that
expectation acts
like center of mass.
So the center of mass, when
these two points are equally
likely, is just the midpoint,
which of course is 2.
So we're going to use that
intuition on the other ones.
So I'm skipping to x is
equal to 2 because 1
and 3 are not possible.
So when x is equal to 2,
y can only take on the
values of 1 or 2.
Again, they're equally likely.
So the center of mass is in the
middle which happens at
1.5 or 3/2.
Similarly, x is equal to 4.
We're living in this conditional
universe, where y
can take on of these
four points with
probability 1/4 each.
And so again, we expect
the center of mass to
be at 1.5 or 3/2.
And this quantity is undefined
otherwise.
OK, so we're almost done.
Now we just need to find which
value of x maximizes this.
Well, let's see, 2 is the
biggest quantity out of all of
these numbers.
So the maximum is 2.
And it occurs when
x is equal to 0.
So we come over here.
And we found our answer.
x is equal to 0 is the value,
which maximizes the
conditional expectation
of y given x.
So part b is very similar
to part a.
But there is slightly more
computation involved.
Because now we're dealing with
the variance and not an
expectation.
And variance is usually a little
bit tougher to compute.
So we're going to start
in the same manner.
But I want you guys to see if
you can figure out intuitively
what the right value is.
I'm going to do the entire
computation now.
And then you can compare whether
your intuition matches
with the real results.
So variance of x conditioned
on a particular value of y,
this is now a function of y.
For each value of y you plug in
you're going to get out a
scalar number.
And that number represents the
conditional variance of x when
you condition on the value
of y that you plugged in.
So let's see, when y is equal
to 0 we have a nice case.
If y is equal to 0 we have no
freedom about what x is.
This is the only point that
could have occurred.
Therefore, x definitely
takes on a value of 4.
And there's no uncertainty
left.
So in other words, the
variance is 0.
Now, if y is equal to 1, x can
take on a value of 0, a value
of 2 or a value of 4.
And these all have the same
probability of occurring, of
1/3,
And again, the reasoning behind
that is that all eight
points were equally likely in
the unconditional universe.
If you condition on y being
equal to 1 these outcomes
still have the same relative
frequency.
Namely, they're still
equally likely.
And since there are three
of them they now have a
probability of 1/3 each.
So we're going to go ahead and
use a formula that hopefully,
you guys remember.
So in particular, variance is
the expectation of x squared
minus the expectation
of x all squared,
the whole thing squared.
So let's start by computing
this number first.
So conditioned on y
is equal to 1--
so we're in this line--
the expectation of x
is just 2, right?
The same center-of-mass
to argument.
So this, we have a minus
2 squared over here.
Now, x squared is only slightly
more difficult.
With probability 1/3,
x squared will take
on a value of 0.
With probability 1/3,
x squared will take
on a value of 4.
I'm just doing 2 squared.
And with probability 1/3, x
squared takes on a value of 4
squared or 16.
So writing down when I just
said, we have 0 times 1/3
which is 0.
We have 2 squared, which
is 4 times 1/3.
And then we have 4 squared,
which is 16 times 1/3.
And then we have our minus
4 from before.
So doing this math out, we get,
let's see, 20/3 minus
12/3, which is equal
to 8/3, or 8/3.
So we'll come back up
here and put 8/3.
So I realize I'm going through
this pretty quickly.
Hopefully this step didn't
confuse you.
Essentially, when I was doing
is, if you think of x squared
as a new random variable, x
squared, the possible values
that it can take on are 0,
4, and 16 when you're
conditioning on y
is equal to 1.
And so I was simply saying
that that random variable
takes on those values with
equal probability.
So let's move on to
the next one.
So if we condition on y is equal
to 2 we're going to do a
very similar computation.
Oops, I shouldn't have
erased that.
OK, so we're going to use the
same formula that we just
used, which is the expectation
of x given y is equal to 2.
Sorry, x squared minus the
expectation of x conditioned
on y is equal to
2, all squared.
So conditioned on y
is equal to 2, the
expectation of x is 3.
Same center of mass argument.
So 3 squared is 9.
And then x squared can
take on a value of 4.
Or it can take on
a value of 16.
And it does so with
equal probability.
So we get 4/2, 4
plus 16 over 2.
So this is 2 plus 8, which
is 10, minus 9.
That'll give us 1.
So we get a 1 when
y is equal to 2.
And last computation and
then we're done.
I'm still recycling
the same formula.
But now we're conditioning
on y is equal to 3.
And then we'll be done with
this problem, I promise.
OK, so when y is equal to 3 x
can take on the value of 0.
Or it can take on
the value of 4.
Those two points happen with
probability 1/2, 1/2.
So the expectation is right
in the middle which is 2.
So we get a minus 4.
And similarly, x squared can
take on the value of 0.
When x takes on the value of
0-- and that happens with
probability 1/2--
similarly, x squared can take
on the value of 16 when x
takes on the value of 4.
And that happens with
probability 1/2.
So we just have 0/2
plus 16/2 minus 4.
And this gives us 8 minus
4, which is simply 4.
So finally, after all that
computation, we are done.
We have the conditional
variance of x given y.
Again, we're interested in when
this value is largest.
And we see that 4 is the biggest
value in this column.
And this value occurs when
y takes on a value of 3.
So our answer, over here,
is y is equal to 3.
All right, so now we're going to
switch gears in part c and
d a little bit.
And we're going to
be more concerned
with PMFs, et cetera.
So in part c, we're given a
random variable called r which
is defined as the minimum
of x and y.
So for instance, this
is the 0.01.
The minimum of 0 and 1 is 0.
So r would have a
value of 0 here.
Now, we can be a little bit
smarter about this.
If we plot the line,
y is equal to x.
So that looks something
like this.
We see that all of the points
below this line satisfy y
being less or equal to x.
And all the points above this
line have y greater than or
equal to x.
So if y is less than or equal to
x, you hopefully agree that
here the min, or r,
is equal to y.
But over here, the min, r, is
actually equal to x, since x
is always smaller.
So now we can go
ahead quickly.
And I'm going to write the value
of r next each point
using this rule.
So here, r is the value
of y, which is 1.
Here, r is equal to 0.
Here r is 1.
Here r is 2.
Here r is 3.
Over here, r is the
value of x.
So r is equal to 0.
And r is equal to 0 here.
And so the only point we didn't
handle is the one that
lies on the line.
But in that case it's easy.
Because x is equal to 2.
And y is equal to 2.
So the min is simply 2.
So with this information
I claim we're now done.
We can just write down
what the PMF of r is.
So in particular, r takes
on a value of 0.
When this point happens,
this point happens,
or this point happens.
And those collectively have a
probability of 3/8 of occurring.
r can take on a value of 1
when either of these two
points happen.
So that happens with
probability 2/8.
r is equal to 2.
This can happen in two ways.
So we get 2/8.
And r equal to 3 can happen
in only one way.
So we get 1/8.
Quick sanity check, 3 plus
2 is 5, plus 2 is
7, plus 1 is 8.
So our PMF sums to 1.
And to be complete, we
should sketch it.
Because the problem asks
us to sketch it.
So we're plotting PR
of r, 0, 1, 2, 3.
So here we get, let's
see, 1, 2, 3.
For 0 we have 3/8.
For 1 we have 2/8.
For 2 we have 2/8.
And for 3 we have 1/8.
So this is our fully labeled
sketch of Pr of r.
And forgive me for erasing so
quickly, but you guys can
pause the video, presumably,
if you need more time.
Let's move on to part d.
So in part d we're given an
event named a, which is the
event that x squared is greater
than or equal to y.
And then we're asked to find the
expectation of xy in the
unconditional universe.
And then the expectation of x
times y conditioned on a.
So let's not worry about the
conditioning for now.
Let's just focus on
the unconditional
expectation of x times y.
So I'm just going to
erase all these r's
so I don't get confused.
But we're going to follow a very
similar strategy, which
is at each point I'm going to
label what the value of w is.
And we'll find the expectation
of w that way.
So let's see, here,
we have 4 times 0.
So w is equal to 0.
Here we have 4 times 1.
w is equal to 4.
4 times 2, w is equal to 8.
4 times 3, w is equal to 12.
w is equal to 2.
w is equal to 4.
w is equal to 0.
OK, so that was just algebra.
And now, I claim again, we can
just write down what the
expectation of x times y is.
And I'm sorry, I didn't
announce my notation.
I should mention that now.
I was defining w to be the
random variable x times y.
And that's why I labeled
the product of x
times y as w over here.
My apologies about not defining
that random variable.
So the expectation of w, well,
w takes on a value of 0.
When this happens, this happens
or that happens.
And we know that those
three points occur
with probability 3/8.
So we have 0 times 3/8.
I'm just using the normal
formula for expectation.
w takes on a value of 2
with probability 1/8.
Because this is the lead
point in which it
happens, 2 times 1/8.
Plus it can take on the value
of 4 with probability
2/8, 4 times 2/8.
And 8, with 1/8 probability.
And similarly, 12 with
1/8 probability.
So this is just algebra.
The numerator sums up to 30.
Yes, that's correct.
So we have 30/8, which
is equal to 15/4.
So this is our first
answer for part d.
And now we have to do this
slightly trickier one, which
is the conditional expectation
of x times y, or w
conditioned on a.
So similar to what I did in part
c, I'm going to draw the
line y equals x squared.
So y equals x squared
is 0 here, 1 here.
And at 2, it should take
on a value of 4.
So the curve should look
something like this.
This is the line y is
equal to x squared.
So we know all the points below
this line satisfy y less
than or equal to x squared.
And all the points above this
line have y greater than or
equal to x squared.
And a is y less than or
So we are in the conditional
universe where only points
below this line can happen.
So that one, that one, that
one, that one, that
one and that one.
So there are six of them.
And again, in the unconditional
world, all of
the points were equally
likely.
So in the conditional world
these six points are still
equally likely.
So they each happen with
probability 1/6.
So in this case, the expectation
of w is simply 2
times 1/6 plus 0 times 1/6.
But that's 0.
So I'm not going to write it.
4 times 2/6 plus 4 times 2/6
plus 8 times 1/6, plus 12
times 1 over 6.
And again, the numerator
summed to 30.
But this time our denominator
is 6.
So this is simply 5.
So we have, actually, finished
the problem.
Because we've computed this
value and this value.
And so the important takeaways
of this problem are,
essentially, honestly, just to
get you comfortable with
computing things involving
joint PMFs.
We talked a lot about finding
expectations quickly by
thinking about center
of mass and the
geometry of the problem.
We've got practice computing
conditional variances.
And we did some derived
distributions.
And we'll do a lot more
of those later.